[Music]
let's talk about the passengers and
suspects aboard the Murder on the Orient
Express well Nancy Daisy Ridley is one
such suspect and she told me how for her
she boarded this film just in time doing
the second stall I remember thinking
should be worried that I don't have a
job after this the first time I heard
about the making us would literally
masane to an audition I was like yes I'm
a big believer in things happening for a
reason so I was like this is why I
didn't have anything lined up I'm
sleeping here where everyone can see me
and I can see everyone the murderer is
on the train with us now and every one
of you is a suspect the ensemble cast of
Murder on the Orient Express also
includes Johnny Depp Penelope Cruz
Michelle Pfeiffer Josh GAD and Hamilton
Tony winner Leslie Odom jr. she really
is a very down-to-earth human being
that's what we love about busy is she
just is always real it's true that's the
only compliment you'll get out of me and
you and Leslie don't even look for one
Josh is clearly their resident class
clown on social media he's been enjoying
every minute of downtime on their
international press tour and they were
that little Instagram video and people
don't think I'm Giggy but I can get
jiggy I said well because here comes I
mean he said he's gonna get jiggy yeah
six
with it that stop being cheap Oh
so I'm not Hamilton Maori both the son
[Music]